you know used to wear to make planes
yeah yeah they were the zero Fighters oh
that's that's a bad plane isn't
itci that's a no no
plane they're not supposed to land yeah
they don't even land there's no
[Laughter]
[Music]
gear so you guys see the the exit row
plane where the yeah the Alaska Airline
plane where the [__] door was gone
737 Max 9 oh my God yeah bro so right if
you don't know uh the if you ever sit in
the emergency row right and they're like
are you prepared to be helpful during an
emergency or whatever yeah sure whatever
I don't give a [__] give me the leg room
and then imagine you're you're sitting
there and then all of a sudden the
[__] door blows off that's crazy and
now you're just like everyone's chilling
thankfully nobody was actually sitting
in the actual seat but aair a chair flew
out apparently a chair if you were
sitting there you would have been like
ejected yeah those [__] are bolted down
it still flew out dude the the door and
the chair are [__] that's [__]
crazy is there anybody like missing a
shirt or
something they're just sitting there
Shir get snap your snap off pants just
your tear away [__] theid huge
[__]
heav wow just a guy without a shirt bro
that's [__] crazy no apparently
everyone like a shitload of phones got
sucked out though w
oh they actually found an iPhone not
kidding like that had survived the fall
I think they found a couple of these
yeah that survived the to the fall yeah
that's like the best branding it just
good case good case Otter Box Otter Box
so how does the door just fly they're
investigating that why don't they make
the whole plane out of the otter
box hey that's good great question don't
roll your eyes like that you commit to
it
okay that same day uh David had a flight
to Hawaii and then it got canceled he
goes bro I got to take the next flight
like this one's canceled I'm like I
wonder why and then this rolls out and
apparently on that same day every single
one of these like plane models they
landed and then they double checked
everything and they found like hella
loose screws on like three of them or
something oh my God so this plane is
they don't they don't check before every
flight I don't n dude that's that's a
waste of Human Resources go just peep
around a corner I've I got to get to
Detroit come on I've seen I've seen like
gum or litter from the last flight
sometime you know when you open the
thing they're not really cleaning yeah
they're just it's just quick they're
just like get up back in the air it is
very quick this is the oh my God that's
what we're dealing with damn that's the
night sky yeah that's the Stars dude it
would be way cooler if it was daytime
that's [__] scary no one on that
flight though huh not a lot of people I
bet it's cold as [__] too holy [__] yeah
better give you something blankets for
that h i mean obviously I don't want
anybody to get hurt but I would like
kind of enjoy being in one of those
situations that's a crazy what if nobody
gets hurt you wouldn't actually like it
I know what you mean like like when you
go through something crazy but then you
come out okay yeah all the adrenaline or
whatever good story and SL it's a good
story and then also you know next time
you get on that plane you're going to be
like well wasn't like that last
time hey uh don't send me in the
emergency road I think if that [__]
happens to me I flying ever again dude
really never again I'd actually feel
safer cuz then after that I'm like the
odds of it happening again is very low
it is true but the odds of happening
even the first time is low already I'm
like damn I must be bad luck I actually
thought that our system was like I felt
more reassurance when I found out they
landed all the planes double checked
everything and I was like wow we have a
really good like no one just let it go
like eh that's one mistake you know you
know when stuff like that happens and
then like everyone on the plane starts
becoming like super religious and
they're like God if you get me out of
this I'll love you forever what's the
rate of like return like do you think
that's a bad Christian bro do you think
over time like all of them stick with
that probably not hell no dude it
depends on what they promise they
probably do for a little bit I think
they go to church for 15 minutes like oh
[__] it's like damn I'd rather just get
sucked out of a plane I think dude God's
never cashing that in though he's not
cashing that in no but he's judging you
on [__] judges look at this dude
[__] sweating [__] 32c look at
this [__] guy dude little [__] I
scheduled him to dial on time ago and
he's over trying to bargain cuz you know
when you when you you're in a plane
there's mad turbulence you see people
kind of like start pring dude that was
me yesterday I watched this guy next to
me uh no no hate but
like just a little hate I'm like this
guy like is a very low intelligence
because every time that it dipped he's
like yo that we just dipped a lot and
it's like no [__] dude no [__] [__]
like the like the pilot could control it
yeah he was like one of those white
dudes who wears the the shorts that are
like all the way
down you don't know if it's short pants
or long shorts yeah yeah it's like he's
still listening to Limp Biscuit yeah and
no and he's watching Tik toks next to me
loudly and I'm like this is
going oh yeah dude I'm like when is
Takeoff coming and he's watching of
course he's watching MMA videos or
whatever and I'm like dude you don't do
MMA bro you're [__] skinny ass legs
and [__] see like I'll your [__] ass
I was literally cuz like I'm already I'm
already just squeezed into a little tiny
little part of Spirit Airlines and I I'm
in the middle I'm like I paid for a bag
I'm in the [__] middle I paid for a
[__] bag let me see who who who
didn't pay for a bag why am I not on the
[__] exit row or at least put me in
the window yeah so I'm already pissed
and then this guy next to me opens up
Tik Tok and he's just like and and all
the audio is different cuz it's like one
one clip has music One clip's a guy
yelling one has the robot voice yeah
exactly dude I'm I'm so secretly mad at
all those people that are hella aloud on
planes oh yeah dude that's not
considerate yeah yeah who do you think
you are bro every little and he's like
yo did you feel that dude holy [__] and
he's like holding his chick's hand what
a little [__] yeah he was a [__] dude
yeah while he's watching MMA videos with
his skinny legs and his long I'm telling
you not a fan of that guy or his shance
whatever you want to call him so every
time there was some turbulence he was
just calling it out he was calling it
out yeah yeah like as if I don't know
why like his friends don't feel it or
something like everyone knows dude was
he trying to get some laugh you think no
he was like Terri okay but like he maybe
couldn't control he's just one of those
expressive ass [__] Motors he's a
motor stop defending him bro I'm just
trying to defend the airport does make
me like hate humans more though no lie
the airport or airplane well just the
entire traveling through air experience
oh people are the worst on yeah it's
like you're either docile and like
acceptable or you're a piece of [__]
ruining things you know what I mean and
then you have to like like come back to
like Humanity senses and like be like no
I still love life cuz there's people
that are like my needs are more
important than anyone else's needs in
this [__] place yeah nobody
else's needs like the crazy thing is
everybody's a [__] main character at
the airport you know what I mean like
just relax yo like we could all just be
supporting Cass in a like a community
let's just get through the TSA line did
you see how about I stop in the middle
of the hallway I got to stop in the
middle of the hallway did you see that
one guy he was being obnox and he was
like challenging this guy and he's like
why are you record or what are you
recording he goes I'm about to I'm
recording a guy that's about to get his
ass bait oh yeah and then he's like hit
me hit me and then as soon as you see
the hit the next cut is he's on the
ground with blood on his face with a Sho
his shoe off he's like being dragged out
oh God and then he's the guy in zip ties
like in trouble while the other guy that
[__] him up is fine and I'm all like
that's so satisfying he was like a boxer
yeah he's a boxer right I'm about to I'm
about to record an ass whooping I'm like
that's the that was so drunk though he
would have got his ass whooped by
anybody on the plan he was so freaking
gone dude I think those are the type of
guys I [__] hate like the obnoxious
drunk people that are just like British
guys on holiday dude my buddy's a a
pilot uh in in he lives in Vegas and he
does the Vegas to LA obviously oh that
must be crazy he's like it's drunko it's
people who just lost gambling it's like
and they're so rude to to the
to the to be fair though to be fair if
you're like consistently doing the LA
Vegas like I mean come on you know
mean what do you mean what's Anthony's
that guy bro's that guy anon's like
doing open mic right now he's like I
mean I think what saying is like if
you're a cop and you work in comp then
it's like you deserve to die yeah get
shot in the face everyone got come on
come on I didn't know I didn't know it
was racial everyone has a good come on
that's all right come on yeah you're
asking for it Vegas to LA a different
flight come on yeah instead of saying
officer down they just go come
on come on sometimes like I love flying
right but then when those things happen
I go I can't wait to be see this is why
I need to be rich I can't fly in a
private plane my suffering is I have to
fly with these [__] yeah yeah
other than that I love flying but it's
like once I'm reminded I'm like ah this
I got to be rich why am I here why am I
[__] seeing next to this person yeah
see even if I make it I'll just be like
why am I so [__] cheap yeah that's
true why do I have to be so
cheap that's how you stay Rich yeah I
mean come on come on hey uh yeah by the
way the um the the CEO of Alaska
Airlines is just like I'm so sorry
everybody had to go through this
traumatic incident my heart goes out to
those who were on this flight I'm sorry
for what you experienced I'm grateful
for the response of our pilots and
flight attendants it's like the door
fell off dude the door fell off and in
the middle of of of you're like 30,000
ft up that's [__] crazy and you're
trying to be all positive by saying like
good job yeah there's no like condolence
you can offer yeah I'd be like yo guys
I'm so sorry the door fell off that's
crazy I feel like the exit door everyone
gets a free flight or something or or
30% off for everybody right now big
promo yeah hey 6 months you guys get to
go to the lounge for six whole
months does Alaska have a lounge I don't
know I don't know not you get to have
the water with the [__] floating
fruits in it and I think they're doing
okay though cuz they just bought
Hawaiian Airlines and then before that
they bought uh virgin so I feel like
alas is pretty good Airline though
typically speaking Yeah it's been fine
minus like doors flying off yeah but
that's you know track record I don't
hold it against Alaska I just think
doors are bound to fly off you know what
I
mean it's just Delta dudes [__]
sabotaging it cuz they're a oh it's
Delta dudes strikes again this plane was
only a Comm for like a year barely
that's a new plane it's a newe why
doesn't Toyota make planes man I know
I'm only fly Toyota or hyund dude yeah
we could jack them
all we would kids Jack [__] Jack with
a USB key yeah you know used to wear to
make planes yeah yeah they were the zero
Fighters no way oh that's that's a bad
plane isn't commercial they're the
comicazi no no plane they're not
supposed to land they don't even there's
no
gear remember in Snakes on a Plane and
Snakes on a Plane when Keenan Thompson
helps land the plane cuz he played the
video game of of it I didn't see that
movie happened in Soul Plane too Soul
Plane was a good movie Soul pl's a
documentary talk about a movie where the
door fell off dude Snakes on a Plane the
door [__] fell off BR D kidding news
careful voice is a brand just kidding
news is the man of smart people the
people of just kidding news careful boys
they are very smart just kidding news
the number one foodcast in the
[Music]
world